[Music]
right a delicious root vegetable hash
brown
with some pork sausages top of the fried
egg and this is a sort of combination of
two countries
a bit like here really because i've got
one foot in finland and over there the
other side of that tree is sweden
okay see that man down there with a mask
he's swedish
he's running away because finn have just
beat them two nil in the soccer look at
this gorgeous setting would you believe
we are in the middle of
summer that's right not winter summer so
this is a sort of
hash brown but using summer ingredients
first off i'm gonna slice the onions
okay
and get them caramelized now i think of
hash browns and it's all about
what have we got left to use what can we
fry up for a delicious brunch dish
now onions in with the most amazing
okay pork sausages
i'm gonna get the sausages nice and tiny
okay slice them up now i want the fat
coming out of the pork
to start flavoring those onions you can
take them out the skin
but i quite like them left in the skin
and just chopped up
nice and rough from there little touch
of oil
onto our furnace and she goes
now from there
in
beautiful now get that frying the
sausages and the
onion now get some color on those
and don't burn yourself
fry those off beautiful
amazing turn the board over for all you
bdis
known for one there's a raw food on
there there you go clean
change the knife wipe it down hot water
i've got some beautiful new potatoes
okay
just literally slice them in half skins
are on
and slice them nice and finely the nice
thing about these potatoes
they're grown locally but they cook so
quickly
they're nice and waxy and they give a
really nice sort of
crispy flavor to the hash
any leftover potatoes then of course we
can just grate them
but thinly sliced in there beautiful
bunch of salt and
now the secret here let's get all those
vegetables
beautifully fried for the color on the
potatoes
nice next to that because it's
summertime here
in finland i've got these beautiful
beets
okay golden beets again
everyone use beets for sort of beetroot
salad beetroot soup
but a fried beetroot honestly so
delicious
just slice them down and for me it gives
a really nice sweetness
to the hash and
as a proper root vegetable the flavors
are incredible
get them in
salt now
let those vegetables fry and beautifully
caramelize
next to that a hash brown wouldn't be
complete unless we got the most amazing
egg so
lightly oil the pan a little knob of
butter
and again get that nice and warm season
that oil first
salt and pepper get that onto the grill
get that melted and then we're going to
crack the egg in there okay
take your herbs okay i've got some
chives and some dill
and again just literally chop
nice and fine and put that
in over those vegetables
beautiful now you can see those potatoes
get nice and crispy
and that beetroot is starting to
caramelize
beautiful those pork sausages have
rendered down
on those potatoes the flavors are
incredible
now my butter's starting to melt get my
egg in there
tap on an even surface in she goes
beautiful and again back on
now bring that up quickly
into the center and get that egg frying
beautifully
now look at the vegetables now look at
that
so beautiful as the egg starts to fry
pull it off to the side and let the
butter
cook the top of the egg beautiful little
season on top of that
salt and pepper and now
we've got all that magic in that
incredible vegetable
the secret there for me is sort of
the addition of the beetroots at the end
it gives that really nice sweetness to
the potato
okay now
look at that color in there
all that potato got nice and crispy
the colors are so beautiful
hot beet root i've always been a massive
fan of especially when it's been roasted
nice and then finally
get your egg make sure
all that white is cooked let the pan do
the work
beautiful and there we go an amazing
half finish half swedish
beautiful root vegetable hash brown
topped with a delicious fried egg
half of finland half for sweden now if
you enjoyed that recipe please click the
link below and if you missed uncharted
then please watch on catch up on disney
plus